do women owe Society children my mom's
life path on this Earth was to be a
mother and she's been through the worst
of losing three kids before she had my
brother then she had my brother 18 years
later then she lost two more before me
then she had me she had to pray at her
gravestone just to be a mother and I was
born so I think it's very important that
we as women should actually take on that
role that's what we're here to do this
is us this is our power to love and to
grow and to transform life like stop
with this selfish thing I don't know
what the world has done to everybody
it's all about me it's all about me see
where life takes us with that